resuelva el triángulo rectángulo que se
muestra a continuación
tenemos que encontrar todos los ángulos
y todos los lados vamos a comenzar con
los ángulos y si recordamos vemos en
este triángulo que hay 60 grados es un
triángulo rectángulo por lo que este es
un ángulo de 90 grados nos vamos a
encontrar que el ángulo y que no sabemos
de cuánto es más el ángulo de 60 grados
que es el doble 1 más el ángulo de 90
grados el ángulo recto que es el x la
suma de todos estos nos debe dar 180
grados
dejar el ángulo y para esto tenemos que
restar 60 y 90 en ambos lados de la
ecuación nos va a quedar el ángulo y
es igual a 180 menos 60 menos 90
esto va a ser igual a 180 60 más 90 o
menos 60 menos 90 es igual a menos 150
180 y 250 va a ser igual a 30 por lo que
este ángulo que nos queda es de 30
grados lo anotamos este es de 30 grados
y con esto podemos calcular los lados a
ive salta a la vista que este es un
triángulo 30 60 90 que se ve muy seguido
en clases de trigonometría veamos cómo
encontrar el lado a ustedes pueden
elegir el método que ustedes consideren
yo lo voy a hacer de dos maneras y voy a
asumir que conocemos nuestras razones
trigonométricas para encontrar estos
lados de esta forma u otra manera es que
si sabemos todo al respecto de los
triángulos 30 60 y 90 lo podemos
resolver de esta otra manera esta última
es más sencilla pero ya que estamos
trabajando con funciones trigonométricas
vamos a resolverlo primero de este modo
podemos usar cualquiera de sus tres
ángulos tomaremos el ángulo de 60 grados
este triángulo conocemos el valor de la
hipotenusa que es el lado más largo y
también es el opuesto al ángulo recto
que es de valor de 10 y para este ángulo
de 60 grados nuestro lado adyacente va a
ser a qué función tiene relación a 2 el
lado adyacente con la hipotenusa pues
para recordarlo vamos a escribir nuestro
neumónicos o kato a su ca
el cono del ángulo es igual al adyacente
entre la hipotenusa por lo que el coste
no de 60 grados que es el ángulo que
hemos elegido va a ser igual aa el
cateto adyacente que es también se llama
aa
entre la hipotenusa que vimos es 10
nos interesa conocer a vamos a
despejarlo y esto lo vamos a hacer
multiplicando ambos lados de la ecuación
por 10
esto lo multiplicó por 10 este otro lado
lo multiplicó también por 10 estos se
cancelan me va a quedar que a es igual a
10 por el coseno de 60 grados
y aquí ustedes pueden usar su
calculadora para resolver esto
pero el coseno de 60 grados es bastante
conocido de hecho vale la pena
memorizarlo también el seno de 60 grados
y el seno de 30 grados y con seno de 30
grados o el de 45 grados a veces uno no
quiere expresar los resultados en
decimales sino en alguna fracción así
que aquí yo sé que el coseno de 60
grados escribo bien los grados es un
medio vamos a anotarlo aquí el coseno de
60 grados es igual a un medio si ustedes
usan una calculadora les va a dar este
mismo resultado por ejemplo saco aquí en
mi calculadora y ya me aseguro que estén
grados y si escribo 60 y obtengo el
coche no me da punto 5 que es igual a un
medio
no recomiendo memorizar cosas pero éstas
sí valen la pena memorizar esta igualdad
de acá por lo tanto si es igual a 10 por
punto 5 o por un medio va a ser igual a
10 entre 2 que es 5
va a ser igual a 5
ahora tenemos que encontrar el valor de
b y usando el ángulo de 60 grados en
este caso el lado b va a ser opuesto a
este ángulo de 60 grados qué función nos
sirve aquí pues nos va a servir son el
seno que relaciona el lado opuesto entre
la hipotenusa asumiendo que conocemos
cuál es el seno de 60 grados qué valor
tendrá b bueno escribimos el seno de 60
grados va a ser igual al cateto opuesto
que es b entre la hipotenusa que
conocemos el valor es de 10 vamos a
despejar b igual vamos a multiplicar
ambos lados de esta ecuación por 10 para
dejar en un solo lado a b eso se cancela
me queda que el lado b es igual a 10 por
el seno de 60 grados pero como les
comenté aquí no tendría que usar la
calculadora y no tendría que trabajar
con un número con muchos decimales
no sé cuál es el valor del seno de 60
grados y es bueno memorizarlo el seno de
60 grados seno de 60 grados es igual a
raíz de 3
entre 2
ese también es bueno de memorizar
los sustituimos aquí ven va a ser igual
a 10 por raíz de 3 entre 2
10 / 12 5 esto nos queda a 5 x raíz de
tres este es el valor de b
lo escribimos b es igual a 5 por raíz de
y con eso terminamos pero hace un
momento mencioné que esos triángulos de
30 60 y 90 grados son muy comunes de
estudiar y pudimos resolver estos signos
funciones trigonométricas de hecho a la
forma en la que recuerdo el valor del
seno de 60 grados y el coseno de 60
grados y también el seno de 30 y el
coseno de 30 grados es por este
triángulo justamente
en general y esa es otra forma de
resolver esto cuando tenemos un
triángulo de 30 60 y 90 en general voy a
escribir aquí un triángulo
que tiene un ángulo de 30 grados otro
ángulo de 60 grados y otro ángulo de 90
grados
y si nuestra hipotenusa es de valor h al
ángulo de 30 grados el ángulo opuesto
pero en el lado opuesto a este ángulo de
30 grados este lado va a valer
exactamente la mitad de la hipotenusa va
a ser h entre 2 este lado y el lado
opuesto al de 60 grados al ángulo de 60
grados el lado opuesto a este ángulo
va a tener como valor raíz de tres
multiplicado por el lado opuesto al de
30 grados es decir x h / 2
lo que nos deja que este lado es raíz de
3 raíz cuadrada de 3 por h entre 2 en
otros vídeos está la demostración de por
qué ocurre esto donde se tiene otro
triángulo rectángulo como espejo del
primero más o menos tienen un triángulo
30 60 y 90 así y en la demostración se
involucra otro triángulo espejo de las
mismas dimensiones pero voltear pero si
conocen este triángulo 30 60 90 y si
conocen el valor de la hipotenusa el
lado más corto valdrá h entre 2 y el
lado intermedio valdrá raíz de 3 entre 2
por h por lo que resolver todo esto
sería bastante simple las hipotenusa es
de 10 el lado opuesto a 30 es la mitad
de h por lo que es 510 entre 12 5 y el
lado opuesto al de 60 grados sería 5 x
raíz de 3 así que este lado queda como
raíz de 3 por 5